I missed Ronnie show last night they did
another car show yeah hey hey jdg tape
any of Ronnie show that show can be for
people I don't know for me yeah
so I was boring a show I've ever heard
of my life for nothing how do you say
most boringest if you went to college
for four years
oh I didn't go to college for how many
years did you go 13 months real college
it's like it's full sale no it's like
it's like a school where you like a
place you learn not to like you take you
go filming video or accordion arts all I
thought you went to college
teach you how to talk there did they
most boring [ __ ]
so you think the car show is horrible I
don't hear your show III get haven't so
if I wanna show you can't even talk
listen I I was in like five minutes
and I got bored I just couldn't I
couldn't deal with it and then I asked
Scott when he came in if he could listen
talking he even pulled me in and said JD
I I can't listen we tried to listen to a
story of him selling the lease on his
truck or something like I couldn't get
through it well people ask these
questions that's what this show is all
about right it wasn't stupid [ __ ] I mean
you can't even talk
where's your show where's your shop so
boring they maybe I should review that
in May because people do like the show
JD yes I'm gonna let you decide
Yeah right I'm giving you the ultimate
power right now I'll cancel that [ __ ]
show
what do you know if it's bad or good
anyway cuz he I'm giving him the power
right now if he tells me to cancel dude
go [ __ ] himself
I don't care if he cancels the show he's
a stupid ass I would feel bad because
it's probably not for my Democrat
because I don't want to cause morning
show is it the most boring show the
first night for us because I got to do
what's right for my mom for my subscribe
it might be for people what were you
saying well it might be for other people
you know people with cars and look in
the cell a car or something
and I I'm just not involved with that
stuff I don't own a car do you want it
off the air or not except for you am i
doing wrong Timmy's trying to intimidate
you I know my [ __ ] show what's their
show cancel JB I know Judi just give me
the word I'll go by your opinion it's
not for me to decide on it is he good
for my channels is it good for your
channels depends on what you're going
for on your channels I'm going for a
show that mainstream that people can
listen to and enjoy yes you know keep it
on or off you want it off the air and be
if it personally offends doesn't offend
me
you take my show off you're a dead
person John Gotti I didn't realize I
didn't really the show is so important
to all right you were bored with Ronnie
show too I just put that clip up on gp2
in red yeah it's Ronnie talking about
buying his leased car I dare you to it's
almost five minutes long I dare you to
get through that okay go ahead
how long we can last exact here we go
every month used car prices keep going
up dealers well yeah of course I'm a
perfect example there cuz I was gonna go
lease a new truck I'm done I'm the GM
guy like GM cars and I went to get a GMC
Denali like I have now they tell me to
get a new one they don't have them they
didn't even make them yet the 2010 I'm
not even in production yet they're not
even they're not gonna start production
until sometime mid-october and if you
then the dealer had no annoying
inventory nothing nothing useful
JT you you left more to show than Mikey
was standing here let's me
a hand under his chin like the thinker
no it wasn't I'm standing just like this
what are you talking about
douche I run all right so far where JT
says keep the shells
it is taped I you didn't pull Clips like
you're supposed to I'm not supposed to
clips if you want clips now interesting
material that's what I try to do subject
this close now we don't need the clips
okay that's fine [ __ ] do you want to
take away Ronnie's show permanent cancel
the [ __ ] show I'm sorry sorry what
the show means you're sorry what so it's
canceled really mean that much doesn't
mean that much you just cancelled it
I know history this was you're an idiot
wine this cuz you're an idiot you don't
want your own show that's not my problem
it means a lot to me okay Ronnie JD can
say whatever okay alright whatever I
don't really care he wants to be like
that that's fine he wants to be an
[ __ ] that's fine
I'll being an [ __ ] on Howard what
[Laughter]
Howard's listeners what do you know you
just stand back there like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and all you do is look at that
telephone screen all morning and running
and at it at [ __ ] bullpen like a
[ __ ] throwing people under the bus
that's my job to look at the hall
looking at me you're a [ __ ] idiot or
sits in a glass booth taking all right
so do your job I I am doing my job
not don't look at the TV I don't care
taking a stand and please take a stand
took it
take my [ __ ] stand also you'll see
what still I take now JD Moonves making
the big decision whatever I'm charting
miscellany whatever whatever what does
he know he doesn't know [ __ ] he doesn't
know [ __ ] about what we do all right
we'll see it's not easy so you know
you've got power okay you got one
[ __ ] thing to do and you take it out
on me that's fine okay okay thank you
well it ain't easy havin power is it and
I didn't ask for this power but it was
bestowed my Superman I didn't ask for
this power all right Thank You JD well
today you are a man that was quite a
moment